actually brother danny from stream facts many
of you may follow stream facts um he he wrote
here please help me to know if i can write
exams on the sabbath or not and why i believe
no no no exams are good but they're not holy
you have six days to write exams write them
from sunday to friday ask for an exemption if you
don't get the exemption honor god god is not to be
obeyed based on negotiation we honor him no matter
what and so ask get a letter from your conference
or your union or the vision whomever do all you
can to be relieved or released from sabbath exams
and sabbath classes if all of that fails you take
a stand for god be faithful to god and remember
first samuel 2 30 them that honor me i will honor
but since the purpose of our lives is to honor god
first put him first don't be intimidated by
what you imagine the consequences to be obey
god regardless remember the message to the church
and smyrna be thou faithful unto death and i will
give the account of like no exams on sabbath
no classes nothing of the kind it's a holy day
and by refusing you may lead someone to
christ as they view your stand for truth
amen amen elder skeet thank you so you even ended
up answering a third question i can i can tell i
can tell you all from experience i've too when i
was taking my shsat um the exam needed to go from
middle school to high school it was on sabbath
i asked my guidance counselor for a letter she
wrote me a letter and i took my exam on sunday
and frankly there were a whole bunch of other
jews that did the same so seven-day adventists
don't feel isolated and the same was for the s.a.t
there is always a way and if god chooses to close
the door and they say no you cannot take the exam
on a day except for the sabbath that's all
these kids that stand for god stand for god